que hatem ben arfa serait sur le point
de signer à l'en avant guingamp
mickaël madar bénard salle en avant
guingamp ce sera l'information de la
journée
c'est un choix qui paraît surprenant
[Musique]
offerts et les cohade mtc que marc moi
j'adore tout le temps la nouveauté elle
c'est un bon jour qui atteint matin la
chaîne juste prendre à thème pardon je
vais prendre j'ai pris des notes de ton
dossier mais tu as pris des notes
en fait c'est parce que je vais
t'expliquer moi à la base je suis pas du
tout footballeur la touche qui connecte
le dal a gelé dit mokhtar façon j'ai pas
je joue je veux pas un respect énorme au
footballeur je le préfère parler en
toute transparence à temps des mecs qui
courent après un ballon sur la vitesse
et on a testé le cas c'est mon ami tu
vois si ça c'est mon ami mais
comment en fait c'est clair que là on a
une situation de crise pour moi donc
clairement tu étais rentré dans une zone
rouge est par contre ouais excuse moi
excuse moi en fait c'est clair que là on
a une situation de crise pour moi tu es
un cas critique aujourd'hui et mokhtar
m'a parlé un peu de toi
de fait clac je jouais plus trop en ce
moment est où ton cas il est grave
non il est pas un j'aimerais vraiment
voir deux distinctions de hockey tu me
lis tu as vu que j'y vais pas trop mais
je connais en tant que prix non c'est
hatem à ta vie tu as ta je suis trompé
tout à l'heure mais là j'ai je suis ok
c'est complexe mais bon j'aime bien le
mot car je suis je vais en train de
service que vois pas ce que c'est un
pote à moi non mais déjà il faut savoir
que moi j'ai rien demandé un engagement
battant il va t'expliquer instant tu
viens je m'attaque je me dis tu t'en fin
tu m'attaques esprit tu vois pas pour
moi ya pas de différence entre un
sportif et un chanteur vous êtes des
produits pour moi tu vois
des produits comme en mai des produits
pour moi vous êtes des produits
c'est-à-dire si je vous tends la main tu
vois je te jette un gilet de sauvetage
mais c'est ça dont les forêts voilà je
suis passé notre tarte à parler de moi
de ce que j'ai réussi un peu les gens
que j'ai fait un peu brillé que j'ai
remis un peu dans la lumière
mamie qui ya félicien du loft la caf et
la comcom manière tu t'en souviens de
tels travaux de l'îlot story et
lorsqu'on est une femme
le premier l'a fait dix ans il part sur
un autre titre là s'est il n'y a pas que
les écureuils qui aiment les glands
c'est un nouveau pas assez drôle mais
c'est dans les clubs échangistes qu'on
va essayer de le propulser
non tu t'énerves ont sérieusement c'est
exceptionnel je te le second challenge
je vais juste honnête de seconde étoile
[Musique]
donc donc tu m'a dit je veux juste voir
ton cv avant pour des scrutins
gg 1 j'ai des gens dans mon entourage
qui sont assez bien placé aussi parce
que j'ai fait jouer des contacts mais ça
je t'en parle un peu pour toi est ce que
tu penses vraiment et j'ai besoin de ses
services
je pense qu'aujourd'hui en date avant de
la servir ton à ton agent on va le
dégager son agent il fait du mauvais
travail parce que sinon on n'en serait
pas là en fait un joueur comme toi ça
devrait pas être sur le banc aujourd'hui
je vais rentrer dans le vif du sujet
aujourd'hui ça me fait chier que toi tu
sois sur le bord ok c'est vrai que tu as
des jambes tu as tu cours vite même si
j'ai vu que tu te donnais pas forcément
toujours un fond sur les matches parce
que j'ai regardé quelques vidéos et pour
moi il ya des problèmes de jeu tu vois
je vois toujours désolé mais qui sont
tout temps plein ils sont ils sont plein
de sueur et tout quand il court vu le
naufrage l'enlève et le terrain comment
ils se trouvent on n'est pas riche et l
échelle mais se réveille et on y va
ensemble un coach michel et chef le
problème dans ta carrière c'est que tu
fais que des rivaux la tomate mais il
prend pas les choses au sérieux a appelé
par son prénom à thème à thème moi ce
qu'on me dit aujourd'hui la pression que
j'ai c'est c'est hatem ben arfa
aujourd'hui il a une image de fils de
[Musique]
mais maintenant c'est de nouveau l'heure
on sait que tu es pas aller à l'école tu
vois que je veux dire c'est un troc aux
ça sans quoi je sais pas enfin tu sais
pas très bien exprimer j'ai très bien
m'exprimer
j'étais à la stresse pas tout de suite
j'ai déjà pas été à l'école après toi je
me sens un petit peu concernés et 28
juin à les footballeurs pour moi ça le
football veut dire quoi ben non ça l'est
pour moi c'est des gens tolèrent dans la
tête c'est ça que je veux sécurité ils
sont exaucés bien sûr mais tu sais avec
tous mes articles je fais comme ça et
j'ai pas de temps à perdre là une image
peu tassé je pense qu'à la thune et je
joue aux poussières battue moi j'en
utilise votre argent je m'en fous je
vibrais pour le ballon peu importe si on
ne paye plus intense mid ces jeux
suivants la phrase que j'aimerais qui
buzz sur les réseaux sociaux
je réessaie je suis ben arfa le joueur
gratos faire d'ailleurs je suis gratos
et toujours avec le sourire c'est à dire
qu'on va faire des sous et on va faire
des gifles on va faire des trucs comme
ça on va faire plein plein de choses
avec ton effigie cas le sourire avec
écrit ben arfa le joueur gratos
ensuite j'ai pensé à un geste ça c'est
vraiment ça va faire rire les gens et en
plus sa belle maman tu marques un peu
quand tu es devant les journalistes
c'est ça c'est l'argent du main elle
aussi mieux non comme ça c'est de
l'argent j'en veux pas tu marques un but
tu cours tu fais comme ça je veux pas de
votre argent je pas de rajouter qu'il
faut rajouter 2 soit pas d'argent
restaure pensais regarder faire gifler
frottements très vite fait graphiste qui
m'a fait ça comme ça tu montres que
c'est le refus de l'argent no money no
money pour moi quoi tu vois
dugarry non je t'explique et déjà est ce
que ça te plaît dans l'attique j'ai
reçus indique soul je me disais comme
quoi il ya une rumeur indy lights bonne
moyenne
le deuxième axe déjà réglé sémalens et
où tu vas jouer
en fait je voulais dire c'est des
joueurs je trouvais à l'époque fabarez
justice c'est ce que je voulais dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il faut tailler à
l'opposé du psg c'est-à-dire pêché ça
pue le fric et moi j'ai envie quand je
dis je suis ben arfa logement est gratos
si je vais aller dans un club qui
correspond à cette philosophie un club
plus modeste et ben tu vas aller à
guingamp et ses deux jambes
comment ces agressions c'est à dire que
mon nom qu'en fait c'est bertrand
desplat c'est le pc le président
guingamp ac tombe
je lui ai dit qu'on travaille ensemble
depuis deux trois semaines et qu'en fait
je me jetais pris sous mon aile école je
vais le faire venir à guingamp
toi tu l'avais dit que j'allais venir
je n'ai eu aucun contact moi j'ai pris
les devants en fait est là et qu'on soit
déçu tout comme moi je suis bizarre
parce qu'en fait je lui ai dit
non et je savais qu'on se voyait
aujourd'hui c'était juste pour qu'on
gagne du temps et que je te sors de ce
merdier
là je conçois détection pour les
détections mm bras
et enfin je prends monument rien il
m'envoyait lesbiennes quand il est là tu
me dis ça parce qu'un truc est déjà
parti j'ai déjà commencé à en parler aux
journalistes
questionné il conclu en fait j'ai des
contacts j'ai parlé à mon goût bertrand
maintenant je te lancer dans le truc
c'est trop tard pour faire marche
arrière
quoi qu'elle marchait et même pas il ya
un peu une marche avant en fait
aujourd'hui si tu signe là-bas moi je
prends soin belmokhtar et transcender
mais est métissée je vais appeler je
vais appeler mon nom
deux secondes mais c'est un phénomène
des films excuse moi là je suis en
compagnie de hatem
je suis atteinte au resto avec lui tu as
commencé à annoncer toi ou pas parce que
il commence à recevoir des textos la non
ya pas la signature mais tu vois par
rapport aux 4 non pas 100 mille passants
mais ses passes en 20 ans et + 0 moi je
te disais c'est le joueur gratos et eps
à la hausse de communication pour ça
buzz
attends je te le pass il en face de moi
je te passe tout l'été
vient de m'annoncer j'ai poussé ensemble
dès que
c'est ça donc là je viens de prendre la
nouvelle excuse et je vais reprendre au
québec
bertrand si bertrand on passe pas par
l'agent non non je sais il est ok il est
ok nom n'y a pas tout ce jour par les
mères à décrédibiliser cheochan non non
ils disent que c'est bon je te dis que
c'est bon il a dit ok c'est bon c'est
chevelure par les jurés raisonnée de
seconde il un peu caractériel mais julio
hockey à tout et je pousserai bases un
peu plus de secondes le slovène tout
[Musique]
ap utah ces normes
j'annonce en deux minutes à l'antenne
c'est qui comme nice et 15 journalistes
c'est clément cachemire infosport est ce
que c'est de mettre la télé si on veut
que tu dois tu comprends ce qui est en
train de se passer
ça fait deux semaines que je parle avec
lui est ce que tu veux vraiment
d'informations il est plutôt évident qu
est ce que tu penses vraiment qu'il va
faire ça
mais qui dit ok mais j'assume j'ai mis
en contact avec bertrand mon poker face
qui va se passer c'est que ça va aller
très vite à partir de maintenant si l'on
va commencer mais c'est un moustique
scopa vous interromps car c'est une
information importante que je viens de
recevoir l'instant parrot par sms d'une
source assez proche d'hatem ben arfa est
manifestement bien informées team
indique que hatem ben arfa serait sur le
point de signer à l'en avant guingamp
mickaël madar bénard sage en avant
guingamp ce sera l'information de la
journée c'est un choix qui paraît
surprenante surprenant de voir signer à
guingamp après avoir été sollicité par
des grands clubs
il a besoin de se relancer il a besoin
de se relancer et grands dans le style
je crois que l'on joue au niveau du
barça qui devrait y avait le barça n'a
remis en juin oui pour que c'est un peu
un peu difficile à comprendre
jean geoffroy ça vous surprend nullement
non parce que je pense que d'abord la
carrière d'un marché en arrière donc un
club il s'appelle en avant pour lui à
mon avis ça peut être que que bien
ensuite c'est un club familial janvier
il faut jouer franchement c'est pas mal
engagée pour le volant c'est là tu vas
pas pouvoir faire des plats merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct sur
sur infosport + président vous avez
conscience que si hatem benarfa rejoint
guingamp puisqu'on en parle là sur
infosport + ce serait probablement le
plus gros coup de l'histoire de votre
club
surtout qu'il accepterait de s'aligner
sur les salaires des cadres qui écrit
demain tu fais tes valises ont par
ailleurs dans tous les trois c'est
pareil dans tous les cas signée on
envoie je suis ben arfa logement gratos
ça ça va redorer son image ça fait aussi
quelques heureux au dessus qui donc sa
décision deux mois le numéro du présent
du psg la pétitionnaire
passer du beau jeu le pré vert pour moi
tu penses vraiment et j'ai saigné la
mettais annoncèrent est annoncée dans
les médias je te sauve ton avenir je te
sauve ton avenir
les quantités réceptionnées exceptionnel
excusez moi je peux vous demander votre
attention s'il vous plaît juste que tout
le monde chambre guingamp avec moi on y
va pour l'arrivée de hatem gare un
accord
[Applaudissements]